all right this is trailer for the new
predator movie the predator cuz in the
world of making sequels that you want to
give really slick subtle titles to
either make it plural or make it
singular but put that in front of it or
he did the plural thing said never dunes
up predator so here we go I'm not gonna
lie when that kid found that alien tech
and he just activated it he started
using it as a spaceship right when he
was activating it I was like oh please
activate the bomb and blow up your town
I don't know why maybe that's just a
little dark how amazing would that be
like rockets and toyed some parents
shouldn't breed it's a reality but then
when the predator ship comes to earth it
doesn't land it crashes with style what
is it in sci-fi movies with a long we
don't just land the ship we crash it was
style I would think the Predators are so
advanced and stealth must be part of
their game because they are in fact
hunters landing a ship really slick like
is probably just their thing but no I'm
just I think I lost Padma quack flying
this thing crash up through the trees
either mr. McGinnes weird and then you
hear it and then predator things start
happening no be honest with you guys if
this was any other movie about a kid who
found an alien wristwatch and a color
ship to earth I'd be like pass I'm not
talking about that [ __ ] turns out
predator is a classic this is a new
installment of said classic so I guess
I'm gonna talk about it I really kind of
don't give a [ __ ] I mean based on this
trailer I don't give a [ __ ] I mean might
be mind-blowing Lee gray it just makes
me think of a VP wreck where the setting
feels like a VP requiem and that weapon
is also a Navy Pier Eklund I do like the
fact they drop Shane Black's name or not
his name but rather the director of Iron
Man 3 who is Shane black it's almost
like they were like alright guys we need
to snare half the Marvel fan base or is
it one third did one third of the Marvel
fans like Iron Man 3 I'm one of them I
actually enjoy Iron Man 3 though I do
get light pissing people off it's not
enough to sell me on it actually when
you're like what do they say they're
making hybrids alone what the [ __ ] did
they say I want to know exactly what
they said I want to get this right oh
[ __ ] Olivia Munn's with this movie
that's right going for an Oscar I say
good for you they're attempting
hybridization they're upgrading on every
planet they visit I don't know exactly
what that means or why they would do
that I got assumed they're not making
human predator hybrids in terms of
genetic superiority I don't think we
hold a candle to them you could argue
Arnold beat the predator in the original
predator and so they're like that got
mocks me that got
something to what they need the ability
to make booby traps they make booby
traps already predator just fell for a
booby traps only reason Arnold won no
maybe the Predators have battled the
aliens so much - like you know there's
something there the whole alien thing is
they annex the DNA of the host maybe we
should start doing that we win in every
alien vs. predator movie so I don't know
why we need to do that I mean they're
physically superior to us and they've
mastered interstellar travel I don't
know what making earth Huibers is gonna
do for them so maybe give them better
eyesight because that is just [ __ ] ass
whatever hybridisation they're doing is
not improving their driving skills at
all obviously good job [ __ ] you hit a
mountain there was nothing but space for
you to see that mountain coming I don't
know it's a great be sci-fi plotline I
mean granted I don't know what this arc
is or why so yes comment section I am
jumping to conclusion and yes comment
section I will actually wait for the
movie to come out but in the world where
I'm talking about the trailer in a video
let's just kind of speculate for a
second we're not speculate let's just
kind of [ __ ] about it because it's the
Internet I just like the fact that the
Predators prove that they're superior by
killing [ __ ] they don't have the innate
need to do hybridization I feel like at
best this movie will have moments that
kind of recaptures the first predator
and other moments that don't so why not
just watch the first predator I don't
know I feel like this was a couple
minutes of me bitching about the new
predator movie I mean they can't all be
fun what can I say sometimes I'm gonna
see a trailer and be like I don't like
that and I'm gonna still talk about it
life is crazy kids watch this is the
coolest [ __ ] predator movie in the
history of predator movies I hope I eat
my words on that I always hope movies
are good I just don't always look good
and I have to assess with what I have
but the predator trailer have you seen
the trailer what did you think about it
keep in mind the kid did not blow up his
town I'm just sayin loses a few points
but are you looking forward to do you
think it looks like [ __ ] whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]